[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hey.
Today we're going to talk about
how to build a custom entity
extraction model with Google
Cloud AutoML Natural Language.
If you've played with the
Natural Language API before,
you might have seen that it
can extract common entities
from text, like the fact that
Google is an organization
or that iPhone is
a consumer good.
But what if you want to tag
more domain-specific entities,
like types of diseases or
the specialized terminology
you might find in legal
documents or patents?
For that, we'll use AutoML to
train and build a custom entity
extraction model.
First we'll need a
labeled data set.
Today we'll build a model that
analyzes patents from Google's
public patent data set.
Using Google Vision's OCR
API, we extracted the text
from a set of PDFs of patents.
Here we've store that data in a
JSON L file, which is the data
type that AutoML Natural
Language expects,
and we've manually
tagged within that text
the character offsets
of the custom entities
we want to extract.
AutoML Natural Language expects
to read our JSON L files
from a Google Cloud bucket.
In addition to our
JSON L data, we'll
make a CSV file that tells
it where in Google Cloud
we've stored our data.
Here we specify which
data files should
be used for
training, validation,
and testing of our model.
If you don't break your data
set into these three files,
AutoML Natural Language will
do it for you automatically.
Now let's upload our data.
Here in the AutoML Natural
Language interface,
we'll create a new data set.
To import the data, we give
AutoML Natural Language the CSV
file we made, and then we wait.
Importing data can take a
couple of minutes to finish,
but you'll get an
email and it's done.
Once our data is
imported we can view
individual examples to make sure
they were labeled correctly.
We can check where in the
text different custom entities
were annotated.
We can also annotate
a new entity right
here from within the tool.
Notice that we can also
tell how many examples we've
got for each label.
We can begin training a
model by navigating over
to the Train tab and
clicking Start Training.
Training a model can
take up to three hours.
Behind the scenes, AutoML will
do a neural architecture search
to find the best model it can.
So now's a good time
to take a coffee break.
You'll get an email when the
model's finished training.
When training is finished, we'll
be able to see our model here
in the Train tab.
We can see how well it
did by clicking here
to See Full Evaluation.
Here in the Evaluate
panel, we can
see the performance of our
model on different labels.
The metrics we'll want to look
at are precision and recall.
Precision tells
us of the snippets
the model labeled Applicant,
how many were really Applicants?
Recall tells us of all the real
Applicants in our data set,
what percent were accurately
recognized by the model?
We can also scroll down to
see where the model correctly
labeled Applicant, these
are the true positives,
and where it accidentally
mislabeled text as Applicant,
or false positives.
In the Test and Use tab,
we can start actually
using our model
hosted by Google.
To do that, we first have
to deploy our model, which
could take a few minutes.
Next we can try to extract
custom entities on a new text
snippet.
There we go.
Here are the custom
entities we extracted.
That's all for now.
Have fun modeling.
[MUSIC PLAYING]